lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
ordenar estas fracciones de menor a
mayor y la forma más fácil o lo que la
gente dice que es la forma más fácil de
obtener esta respuesta es encontrando un
denominador común porque si no podemos
encontrar un denominador común estas
fracciones serían muy difíciles de
comparar por ejemplo cuatro novenos con
13 15 a bosch etcétera puedes intentar
estimar las usando decimales pero podría
ser un poco engorroso así que el truco
aquí será buscar primero el denominador
común muy bien hay muchas formas de
hacerlo simplemente uno podría
multiplicar todos los denominadores y
ese sería un múltiplo común pero bueno
en realidad puede ser también un número
muy grande otra forma es factor izando
estos números en números primos este
mínimo común múltiplo debería tener cada
uno de los números primos así que vamos
a hacerlo de esta forma y luego a
comprobarlo
muy bien entonces el 9 se descompone
como 3 por 3 por lo tanto nuestro mínimo
común múltiplo debe tener estos dos tres
como factores el 4 se descompone como 2
por 2 y por lo tanto debe tener también
estos 2 2 en su factor y zación el 5
pues sólo se puede expresar como 5 así
que lo colocamos ahora el 12 esto será
lo mismo que 2 por 6 lo cual a su vez 6
es dos por tres
ahora si nos damos cuenta estos dos dos
ya están acá abajo
muy bien que ya los hemos subrayado y
este 3 pues es uno de los tres que ya
habíamos tomado otra manera de pensar
esto es que algo que es divisible entre
9 y 4 también va a ser divisible entre
12 a continuación y por último vamos a
tener que para la factorización del 15
vamos a ocupar
3 y 15 es decir 15 es 3 por 5 pero otra
vez ya tenemos un 3 de este lado y un 5
de este otro lado así que este es
nuestro mínimo común múltiplo lo único
que tenemos que hacer ahora en este
momento es hacer el producto de estos
factores muy bien entonces esto que nos
va a quedar 3 x 3 es 9 por 2 es 18 por 2
son 36 y por 5 bueno uno podría hacerlo
mentalmente pero lo voy a hacer de este
lado 36 por 5 nos queda 5 por 6 son 30
30 y llevamos 3 y 3 por 5 son 15 y 3 son
18 por lo tanto nuestro mínimo común
múltiplo es 180 ahora queremos volver a
escribir todas estas fracciones con 180
en el denominador entonces nuestra
primera fracción será 180 como
denominador y 180 entre 9 nos da 20 muy
bien ahora para obtener el numerador
déjenme escribirlo de esta forma 4
novenos
por abajo lo multiplicamos por 20 para
que nos dé 180 correcto y ahora para que
esta fracción no se altere pues hay que
multiplicarlo por 20 muy bien entonces
por arriba que nos queda
nos queda 80 y abajo 180 muy bien
entonces 4 novenos fueron ochenta 180
vos vamos con tres cuartos nos
preguntamos por qué el número hay que
multiplicar a cuatro para que nos dé 180
o en otras palabras 180 entre 4 cuánto
es bueno pues no tenemos que 4 por 45
nos da 180
ok ahora para que la fracción no se
altere hay que multiplicar el numerador
también por 45 ok ahora en el numerador
que nos queda 3 por 45 esto es igual a
correcto ahora 4 por 45 son 180 vamos
con el caso de cuatro quintos ok para
obtener 180 con un 5 como factor
necesitamos multiplicar por 36 nos da
180 correcto de hecho ya lo habíamos
hecho acá arriba si lo ven en verde
tenemos que 36 por 5 es 180 ahora para
no afectar lo multiplicamos también en
el numerador
finalmente 5 x 36 184 x 36
eso eso cuanto nos da bueno esto es 144
muy bien sólo tenemos que hacer 2 más
vamos a continuar con 11 doceavos ok
otra vez nos preguntamos por qué el
número hay que multiplicar a 12 para que
nos dé 180 bueno 12 por 10 son 120 así
que nos faltan 60 en total tendríamos
que multiplicar por 15 recuerda también
en el numerador entonces 12 por 15 son
180 en el denominador y 11 por 15 cuánto
es 11 por 15 bueno 10 por 15 son 150 y
otros 15 son 165 finalmente vamos a
verificar cuánto es 13 15 a vos
muy bien para obtener 180 con un 15 como
factor hay que multiplicar por 12 y lo
vimos en la fracción anterior así que
multiplicamos por dos en denominador y
nos da 180 y también en el numerador muy
bien ahora con 313 por 12 bueno 12 por
12 son 144 si le sumamos otro 12 nos va
a quedar simplemente 156 ok 144 más 12
son 156
ahora ya hemos vuelto a escribir todas
estas fracciones con un nuevo
denominador común que es lo que vamos a
hacer ahora ahora es muy fácil
compararlas sólo tenemos que comparar
sus numeradores por ejemplo el numerador
más pequeño es 80 entonces 4 novenos
será el menor de todos estos números así
que déjame escribirlo por acá vamos a
poner que el número más pequeño fue 4
novenos o bien en su otra expresión 80
sobre 180 ok el siguiente número más
pequeño parece ser 135 entre 180 que era
tres cuartos entonces lo escribimos
bueno déjenme usar el mismo color que
llevábamos es 135 entre 180 que era lo
mismo que tres cuartos muy bien
ahora cuál es el siguiente número más
pequeño
bueno pues fijémonos en los numeradores
y éste parece ser 144 entre 180 que es
equivalente a 4 quintos el siguiente
cuál va a ser el siguiente pues será 156
sobre 180 ok
que es equivalente a 13 15 años
muy bien y por último el más grande que
tenemos es 165 entre 180 vamos a
escribir los 165 entre 180 que es
equivalente a 11 doceavos y ya hemos
terminado finalmente cómo quedan
ordenados de menor a mayor
bueno es justamente como está en este
recuadro amarillo